thank you very much you can thanks for
having me for this talk
oops okay oops
okay so title I'm not sure about the
title what it has to do with the talk
but what I want to do in this talk is
kind of give you a glimpse into
algorithms research and I'm gonna do
that by focusing on one particular
problem and many different results
related to this problem so the problem I
want to talk about is the assignment
problem or maximum weighted matching the
input here is a bipartite graph you have
here with weights on the edges and the
goal is to output a matching so a set of
edges that share no common end points
that maximizes for the purposes of this
talk I'm always talking about
maximization the sum of the weights on
the matched edges so for example in this
graph these orange edges have a total
weight of eight and they provide give
you the maximum weight in matching a
special case that's very interesting and
important and I will probably talk about
quite a bit in the talk is the case
where all weights are equal to one so or
zero and so we represent the one at ones
with with edges and the goal is simply
to find the largest possible matching so
in this case it's the orange matching
and we'll use the term perfect matching
when every single node in the graph is
matched okay so why did I decide to talk
about this problem I couldn't figure out
what to talk about so I just talked
about this problem and the reason is
that it really is a treasure trove and
there's been immense amounts of work on
this problem so first of all it has
endless applications and I'll discuss a
lot of those applications later in the
talk but for right now you can think
about you know matching men and women or
jobs and employees and so on it actually
has a very glorious mathematical history
which I'll be telling you a little bit
about it's one of the cornerstone
problems in the development of
combinatorial optimization
it's a showcase for beautiful beautiful
algorithmic results and I can use it to
illustrate some of the complexities that
we're dealing with now in our special
semester on algorithms and uncertainty
so my hope is to give you a little bit
of a taste of most of the points that
are on this slide so here's what I'm
going to do in the talk I'm going to
give a very partial history to touch on
the glorious mathematical as history of
this problem and then there's then going
to be relatively short technical piece
where I'm going to present a gem and my
criteria for a gem was that it had to be
something beautiful and clever and
elegant but something I could more or
less explain in 15 minutes so I'm going
to actually try to give more or less a
complete proof for one result that I'll
tell you about later then we'll talk a
little bit about online algorithms in
the context of matching and the
assignment problem and some of the new
questions that we're trying to address
now that relate to a lot of the online
market platforms okay so let me start
with a very partial history many many
missing references okay
so the history of this problem is over a
hundred years old
so some of the foundations for bipartite
matching and especially unweighted
bipartite matching were laid by the
Hungarian Danish Koenig in terms of
graphs and the algebraic Frobenius in
terms of matrices Koenig wrote a pair of
papers in 1916 that had many of the
important results about bipartite
bipartite matching when I just say
bipartite matching I mean unweighted
just in general and both of them proved
a version of the so-called marriage
theorem that was rediscovered later by
Phillip Hall and has come to be known as
Hall's marriage theorem so what does
this theorem say suppose we have n men
and n women and an edge between a woman
and a man means that they're compatible
and the question is to characterize when
it's possible to match to come up with n
marriages to match
every woman with with one man or
one-to-one matching so the marriage
theorem as I'm sure many of you know is
that it's possible to do this if and
only if for every set of K men they code
they're collectively compatible with at
least K women so for example here these
two men are compatible with only this
one woman and that's a proof that
there's no no perfect matching in this
graph no way to match everybody so it's
kind of obvious that this sufficient is
is necessary but the marriage theorem
says it's also sufficient okay a very
major development in the theory of
matching was the Hungarian of regards
proof in 1931 of a min/max relationship
so what he showed is that there's a set
of numbers you can associate with the
vertices in the graph and suppose that
the set of numbers cover each of the
edges in the sense that if I sum the
weights the two numbers across any edge
their sum is at least the value on that
edge
okay so among all such sets of numbers
let's find the set that minimizes the
total sum that's called the minimum
cover and he proved that the weight of
that minimum cover is equal to the
weight of the maximum matching in the
graph and so this is actually some of
you probably recognize that this is this
is an instantiation of linear
programming duality for this problem and
this was a tremendously important
development that that led to two later
algorithms although linear programming
duality itself and not yet been
developed at this point but people were
starting to get very interested in
algorithms for very practical reasons
there were a lot of real assignment
problems that people wanted to solve and
people were starting to understand that
having a finite algorithm was not
sufficient to be able to solve it so for
example there was a psychologist named
Thorndike who was working on
assignment problems for the purpose of
classifying military personnel and you
know he went to mathematicians and asked
him for help you know he really wanted
to solve these problems he asked him for
help and they say oh well this is a
solved problem just try all the
permutations and take the best one and
he was kind of frustrated by this and I
went to quote him you know rather cold
comfort to the psychologist when one
considers that only ten men in 10 jobs
mean over three and a half million
permutations so it may be a mathematical
solution but it's not a practical
solution so another great person who
worked on this problem was Julia
Robinson the the great mathematician who
was later a professor at Berkeley by the
way she was actually at the RAND
Corporation in the late 40s early 50s
with a bunch of other great
mathematicians and she was working on
the Traveling Salesman problem and she
came up with a cycle canceling method to
solve the assignment problem that was
actually you know a good portent
precursor to some of the ideas that
turned out to be very important and she
although didn't prove anything about
running time here she thought it would
be a reasonable approach in practice at
the same time okay von Neumann and
dhansak were in the process of
developing linear programming and linear
programming duality motivated largely by
world war ii applications
von neumann in the context of zero-sum
games was doing this and so one at a
lecture he gave at Princeton in 1951 he
formulated the assignment problem as a
zero-sum game I'll just quickly describe
this formulation for the unweighted case
just bipartite matching so we have some
streets in Manhattan let's say and we
have at certain intersections there are
safe houses and there's a cop and a
robber okay so the robber needs to
choose a safe house to hide in and the
cop is going to choose one of the
streets or avenues to drive down and the
cop wins the game
if he drives down the street where the
robber is hiding a street where the
robber is hiding so in this case if he
drove down 2nd Street for 4th Avenue
since the robber is hiding right here he
would win the game ok so finally man
proved that the optimal strategy in this
zero-sum game for for the robber is to
actually find a maximum matching in the
corresponding bipartite graph so the
bipartite graph is between the streets
and the avenues with an edge if there's
a safehouse on that corner and find a
maximum matching in that and then hide
equally likely at any of the locations
in that maximum matching and the optimal
strategy for the the cop is to find a
minimum cover so a minimum set of
streets and avenues that will cover all
of the safe houses and choose at random
one of those so basically he reproved at
regards theorem in the context of
zero-sum games now at the same time
dhansak had recently developed a simplex
algorithm and basically showed that the
assignment problem is a linear
programming problem with an integer
optimal solution and showed that using
one of the fastest computers of the day
that you could solve a 10 by 10
assignment problem with the simplex
method in 20 minutes okay so the big
breakthrough came in the mid 50's when
Harold could developed the first
polynomial time algorithm and this was a
really cornerstone paper and this is
actually a citation for the paper that
came some 50 years later but this paper
and developments at this time in integer
and linear programming were very
important for the sort of development of
the whole field of combinatorial
optimization and the development of
primal-dual type algorithms so he called
his algorithm the Hungarian method even
though he was American and the reason is
that he as he as he says himself the the
ideas for his algorithm were latent in
the works of Koenig and never gari
and he describes you know sort of
realizing I'm coming up with some of
these ideas reading konig's graph theory
book and seeing a footnote in that book
referring to ever Gary's paper which was
in Hungarian and then he went out and
basically knew no Hungarian but he got a
dictionary and he spent two weeks
learning Hungarian translating the paper
and realized that he could combine the
ideas in this paper with Koenig's ideas
to get an efficient algorithm and he
describes how he solved several twelve
by twelve assignment problems in under
two hours each and says this must have
been one of the last times when pencil
and paper could beat the largest and
fastest electronic computer in the world
so okay so and then monk crash action
I'm not sure how to pronounce his name
Mon coeurs and one crash I'm not sure
okay anyway an American another American
who observed that the algorithm runs in
actually time which is strong and
strongly polynomial time so in time that
doesn't depend on the numbers on the
edges but rather just on the number of
vertices in the graph and there were
some numerous subsequent sharpening of
more and more efficient algorithms for
assignment including very important work
by de Karp and and others and there are
so many papers on this topic that I
can't even list him on this slide an
interesting PostScript is that in 2006
it was discovered that the great 19th
century mathematician Jacobi had
actually written a set of manuscripts
around 1836 published posthumously
written in Latin that derived an
algorithm similar to kun-sun garyun
algorithm Hungarian method and he was
solving some differential exists among
and it showed how to reduce the problem
he was solving to the problem solving an
assignment problem and then came up with
his own algorithm although even the
terminology was not available at that
time the word matrix wasn't even hadn't
even been invented at the time that he
wrote his paper
so but I should say that [ __ ] took this
in you know very well and he went around
and gave a talk in 2007 called the
Hungarian method for the asana problem
in how Jacobi beat me by a hundred years
so it was a very good-natured guy it
appears I never managed but so that's my
brief history I will just also mention
that there's huge strands of really
interesting literature related to the
assignment problem having to do with
algebraic approaches and random
assignment problems and counting
matchings and economic literature and
I've put pictures of berkeley professors
some of the berkeley professors who made
really fundamental contributions on
these topics this is David the David
gale who is a great mathematician and
economist who worked a lot on matching
and competitive equilibria type problems
so there's a whole parallel literature
in economics that was very interesting
and this is I mean I assume you know the
computer scientists but the this is
David Aldous from a statistics
department who did a lot of great work
on random assignment problems and
actually yeah anyway so I figure you
gotta like the talk if UC Berkeley
professors on a slide so okay so we've
come to the technical little technical
part I want to show you one really
really cool result and it's about
matching and bipartite graphs so there's
an extensive history of important
developments just on the basic bipartite
matching problem I'm not going to
discuss any of these except to observe
that for you know this general bipartite
matching problem if n is the number of
vertices and M is the number of edges
then we don't know of any linear time
algorithm linear in the number of
vertices and edges for for this problem
however when we restrict attention to
the special case where every vertex has
the same degree okay in this case it's
known that the graph has a perfect
matching in fact D perfect matchings
then a series of developments led to the
development of a linear time algorithm
for this problem so you could solve the
problem finding
in a regular bipartite graph in linear
time so what I want to tell you about is
a relatively recent paper by go L copper
Levin Khanna and in their paper they
prove that you can't do any better than
this if you're going to use a
deterministic algorithm okay but they
were able to come up with a sub linear
randomized algorithm of course this is
sublinear if the degree is large larger
than log n okay and I'm gonna try to
explain this result to you because I
think it's super cool and pretty can be
more or less explained relatively
quickly I hope okay so the key idea is
to use the key idea in finding matchings
in bipartite graphs or a key idea is the
idea of an augmenting path so suppose I
have a partial matching then an
augmenting path is just an alternating
path of unmatched edges with matched
edges that starts and ends with an
unmatched edge so if I have an
augmenting path for a matching let's say
of size two then now if by finding that
augmenting path I have a matching of
size three namely switch from the purple
edges to the blue edges okay so an
obvious way to find a matching is just
repeatedly oh I should also say that
when there is no more augmenting paths
then it the matching is provably of
maximum size so a natural way to find a
matching is just to just grow the
matching by repeatedly finding an
augmenting path and the obvious way to
do that is using some kind of search
algorithm like breadth-first search if
you do that then finding an augmenting
path will take linear time and that
would yield an algorithm that runs in
time basically an n so your augmenting
every time getting one new edge so the
new idea that copper loved' all had is
to use random walks to do much better so
I'm going to explain to you how they go
about constructing their random walk in
order to get efficiently find an
augmenting path
so it's going to be a series of steps
till I get to the actual construction
but here let's let's go so suppose you
have a partial matching first thing
you're going to do is orient every
matched edge up and all other edges down
so it's kind of immediate that if
there's an augmenting path on the top
graph then there's a corresponding
directed path on the bottom graph okay
and the other thing I want you to
observe right now is you know if we
think about the we have the vertices
that are unmatched and the vertices that
are matched so in this directed graph
the top unmatched vertices each have out
degree D the bottom unmatched vertices
each have n degree D in my example D is
2 because degree of every vertex is 2
and the top matched vertices have out
degree D minus 1 and the bottom matched
vertices have n degree of D minus 1 ok
so now what I'm going to do is contract
match edges so I'm just going to
identify the two endpoints so there will
be no more matched edge and leave all
the other edges intact so the result of
this step is that now for the matched
vertices these super vertices the they
each have both in degree D minus 1 and
out degree D minus 1 ok and now what I'm
going to do is extend this graph to
makes make it so that the entire graph
in the entire graph every vertex has the
same in-degree and out-degree
so what I'm going to do is add two
vertices let's say s and T S will have D
edges to each of these vertices that had
out degree D and there will be D edges
from each of the vertices that had n
degree to t and then I'm going to also
have the same number of edges coming
into T which is equal to the number of
edges going out of s from T to s so the
result of this transformation is that
the in degree in this final graph at
every node is equal to its out degree
moreover if there is an argument in the
original graph for example this one that
we were looking at before then there's a
corresponding path in the new graph from
s back to itself so boom boom boom boom
boom boom okay so what does this tell us
if I want to find an augmenting path in
the original graph what I can do is
simply find a path in this graph from s
back to itself okay and I'm going to do
that by running a random walk so how
will this random walk work from every
vertex I'm going to pick a uniformly
random edge to traverse okay and since I
want to find a path back to where I
started I just need to bound the
expected time for this random walk
starting at s to get back to us okay and
I'm going to call that expected time H
sub s s the hitting time starting at us
to get to s now we know that for nice
Markov chains otherwise called ergodic
the fundamental theorem of Markov chains
tells us that that hitting time is
exactly 1 over the stationary
probability of the node s what's the
stationary probability of a node in a
Markov chain it's the long run frequency
of being in that node ok it's also a
solution to this system of equations
it's stationary in the sense that once
you have this distribution over where
you are you have that same distribution
at the next step okay and this should be
kind of intuitive because if the
expected time for me to starting at s to
get back to s is H sub s s then the I
spend roughly you know my frequency of
being in state s is 1 over that hitting
time ok so now we know we can find an
augmenting path in time that's roughly
this hitting time and all we need to do
is figure out what this stationary
distribution is to compute it but it
this is where we take advantage of the
fact that the in degree of every node is
equal to the out degree because for such
graphs for such random walks we can
prove easily that the stationary
probability of each node is its
outdegree divided by the total number of
edges okay and this is a proof of that
fact but we're not going to go through
that so we now have the stationary
distribution which means we now know the
expected time for this random walk to
come back to where it starts and with
indeed with suitable data structures you
can actually find this augmenting path
with that time so now we just need to
put this all together to figure out what
the running time of the algorithm is so
we just said that each augmenting path
can be found in time proportional to
this return time from s to itself in an
iteration where we have I edges in the
matching so here I is to the out degree
of node s is d times and minus I and the
total number of edges in the graph is
just DN for the original graph at most
DN plus D times n minus I out of s and
into T and from T to s okay so this
enables us to do a quick calculation and
argue that the return time from s to
itself is basically an over N minus I
plus 3 at most that
and therefore our total expected running
time we're on menteng end times to get
bigger and bigger matchings our total
expected running time is the time for
each of those random walks which is
easily shown to be O of n log n so
whether or not you've got that or not
this is a really cool way of solving
this problem very efficiently
it gives sub linear running time when
the degree is large and so in my opinion
this classifies as a true gem okay but
in case you didn't follow that part you
don't need to know anything about that
for the rest of the talk okay I'm now
going to turn to something totally
different okay so so far we've been
discussing this traditional algorithms
perspective where you're given the whole
input and you want to compute the whole
output efficiently in this case the
inputs the bipartite graph and you want
to find maximum matching efficiently but
this doesn't capture many of the
real-world settings where we want to
solve problems where in particular we
need to start computing outputs before
we ever see the entire input and
applications of this sort of thing
include memory management and scheduling
or load balancing dynamic data
structures routing and also matching
okay is an important setting where you
often want to solve the problem want and
need to solve the problem online
so let's define a version of this
problem for online bipartite matching
let's just for concreteness think of a
graph between women and men where an
edge means that the man and women are
compatible so here's I'm going to define
a particular online problem
the men are all there to begin with and
the women show up one at a time and when
a woman shows up you learn who she's
compatible with and you need to make an
irrevocable decision as to who to match
her to and the goal is to get a matching
nearly as large as what you would have
gotten had you known the entire graph
ahead of time so you're making decisions
as you go without knowing the whole
graph and the way we're going to
evaluate the quality of an algorithm is
using something that we call the
competitive ratio so for any particular
online algorithm a we're going to look
at the worst-case ratio over the size of
the matching it produces and the size of
the optimal matching so what we have
here is kind of a game between the
designer the algorithm designer and the
adversary who's trying to
whatever your algorithm is the adversary
is going to try to give you inputs that
make this thing very very large ok so I
want to show you immediately that if
you're going to use a deterministic
algorithm you can't do better than 50%
in other words there's no online
deterministic algorithm that can
guarantee on every input that the size
of the matching it finds is at least 50%
of the optimal matching so here's why I
mean here's just a very simple example
so suppose I have woman 1 shows up and
she's compatible with both men your
algorithm is going to choose one of
these edges to match her she's your
algorithm will either match her with man
1 or with man 2 but whatever you do the
adversary knows your algorithm so the
average there is just going to make sure
you let you screw it up so if you
matched her with man 1 then woman 2 will
show up who can only be matched with man
1 if you match her with man two women 2
will show up can only be matched with
man 2 so you will get what your matching
will be of
whereas in both cases the optimal
matching has size two and I can repeat
this of course any number of times to
get a graph as large as I want but the
point is that your algorithm is not
going to get better than 50% on this
kind of search in this kind of situation
now one thing you could consider doing
is randomizing to try to foil the
adversary and this is a one of the most
beautiful and important techniques we
have in theoretical computer science we
already saw it in the previous algorithm
I described but but the the idea is of
course if if your algorithm chooses at
random which man to match her to match
women 1 2 then the adversary not knowing
the random choice but knowing that your
randomize is going to screw up at least
half the time right so basically what
will screw up half the time exactly and
you will basically with probability 1/2
you'll be able to get a matching of size
2 with probably one half you'll be able
to get a matching only of size 1 so now
you'll be able to get 75% of the optimal
algorithm so this so we can ask the
question now is it the case that
randomizing produces guarantees us this
kind of very good competitive ratio
something like 75% that we're getting in
this example and the answer is no it
does not work well at all in fact it
doesn't really work better than 1/2 to
simply choose a random available
neighbor to match the newly arriving
woman to so let me try to just quickly
show you that so here I have a bipartite
graph and the women are divided up into
two groups of size n L and L Prime the
men are divided up into two groups of
size n are in our prime every woman in L
has an edge to every man in our prime
and but the perfect matching in this
graph is the cross matching the the
horizontal matching and suppose the
women arrive in this order ok so the
first woman that arrived has n plus 1
neighbors she chooses one at random
so her chance of matching across
is is that most one is one over n plus
one the next woman to arrive has at
least n neighbors up here so her chance
of matching across is at most one over n
the third woman to arrive has at least n
minus one neighbors up here so her
chance of but I might have gotten my off
by one but anyway the point is that
after these women in L arrived because
they have so many edges up to the top
they're very likely to mostly match to
the top and what you can show with a
simple calculation is that ask just
after the women in L arrived only about
log n out of the n men in are are
actually matched what that means is that
almost none of the men in our prime are
available so that when these women
arrive who can only match across there
they're sunk there's nobody there for
them to match to so this analysis of
this example shows that really if you
just match at random you're not really
going to beat this 1/2 asymptotically
this 50% so so in an ingenious result by
dick Karpin wish buzzer Ronnie and VJ
buzzer Ronnie they actually came up with
a different randomized algorithm that
gets a significant improvement over the
50% and what is their algorithm what
they do is initially they randomly
permute the men and then when a new
woman arrives they assign her to the
highest ranked available man that she's
compatible with so this sounds almost
the same but what's happening here is
that these these random decisions are
getting correlated between the different
women and what they can show magically
is that this gets you up to 63%
competitive ratios they can guarantee
you always get at least 63 percent of
the optimal and also this found is tight
there's no randomized algorithm that can
get better than 63 percent okay so this
is a really amazing result and it was
actually very prescient for a lot of
work that's going on
and in the last 10 years for example
which which involves generalizations of
this problem one of the examples is ad
auctions I mean we know we're all being
bombarded by ads you know when you do a
search on Google you get some ads along
with your regular search results when
you go to Facebook you see ads and so on
how do those ads get there it's some
kind of complicated matching process
that's going on online okay and so
people have been considering like meta
seborrhea buzzer running for server
buzzy Ronnie generalizations of the
online bipartite matching they're quite
a bit more general I'm not going to
really define this but that you know
kind of extend this online bipartite
matching result and also are able to get
in quite a more complicated setting also
at least 63% of the optimum revenue in
this case so I'm not going to explain
this I just want to say that you know
that result of Dickson who mentioned
Vijay was you know a precursor to a huge
body of recent literature that has been
very very important in online matching
and it's part of a beautiful and growing
literature this literature for example
has has led to the development of some
very nice design methodologies for
online algorithms based on the
primal-dual framework breakthrough
results on a variety of problems and
also kind of orthogonal II I just want
to mention a significant literature on
online problems in stochastic settings
okay so the last thing I want to do for
the last few minutes is talk about the
new frontier okay so I chose us to talk
about assignment problems because so
many of the modern applications that
that we care about and are interested in
involve assignment so we're doing
matching all the time for example eBay
Amazon and Etsy or matching buyers with
sellers and product
uber and lyft are matching drivers with
passengers Airbnb is matching travelers
with lodging Ilan's and oDesk are
matching employees with employers we
discussed matching ad slots with
advertisers we're matching Oregon donors
with recipients we're matching people
looking for love with other people
looking for love so there are a lot of
matching problems that are getting
solved all the time out in the real
world and a question is what can we as
algorithm designers contribute to the
understanding of all these and many
other problems so I just kind of want to
give explain a little bit about what
some of the new issues that arise in
these modern settings so let's go back
to the example of selling advertising
slots so suppose you have a search
engine with advertising slots for sale
and you have a set of advertisers and
the number on the edge is how much it's
worth to the ad or how much the
advertiser is willing to pay to have
their ads shown in this particular slot
so from the perspective of the search
engine who's trying to make money they
would like to find a maximum weight
matching here and basically just charge
those advertisers those numbers the
problem is that these numbers are the
private information of these advertisers
and these advertisers are not just going
to tell the search engine exactly how
much they're willing to pay especially
if they can you know get what they want
at a lower price so for example you know
this advertiser here if he knew that
that this was the exact scenario and
that the algorithm was going to be
maximum weighted matching might want to
say well I'm only willing to pay three
instead of five because then he'd get
the same slot but he would have saved
two dollars or whatever this represents
so what we have here is actually a game
a game between the advertisers the
advertisers are competing with each
other for these slots they have to
decide on their strategy of what to
report to the search engine they have to
do that by making some assumptions about
what the other advertisers are doing and
so this is a game in the sense
game theory and you know for example in
the context of Google's search auctions
Google gets to design the game the
advertisers play the game and the
question is how should this game be
designed so that the result is as
effective as possible taking this
strategic behavior into consideration so
this is just one of the important
features of all these modern
applications the nodes in the bipartite
graphs that we deal with in these modern
applications are strategic you know if
you're a passenger using uber you want
to get the cheapest ride possible in the
quickest amount of time if you're a
driver you want to get paid as much as
possible so there's a lot of room for
manipulation and strategy on the part of
all the participants in all of the
examples that I gave earlier another
really interesting saying is that the
platform's the designers of the systems
by which these matching is taking place
have the opportunity to incentivize
behavior one way they can incentivize
behavior is how by their choice of how
information is disseminated to the
participants so for example in uber you
don't get to choose which driver you
want you they do the assignment in an in
a centralized fashion you don't actually
know anything about what's going on in
that graph when you order your uber on
the other hand when you you know buy
stuff on Amazon or Ebay then you get to
see a lot of search results and you make
the choice of who to who what to match
with and the however even there there's
a lot of control on the part of the
platform in in a lot of ways that they
can affect your behavior in particular
in terms of how they rank search results
that has an important impact on how you
choose your match so there's a lot of
interesting questions there about how to
how and what information to disseminate
of course the second key way that a
platform has an opportunity to
incentivize behavior is via pricing so
for example surge pricing
uber is guarantees that or is an attempt
to make sure that when there's heavy
demand for drivers the drivers will show
up because they're going to get paid
more another key feature of these
applications is very complex dynamics so
not only do we have nodes arriving and
departing and we have incomplete
information we don't actually
necessarily know the values on all the
edges maybe we have some stochastic
information and another aspect of the
complicated dynamics is that because
individuals are trying to match
themselves they might try matching with
a number of different possibilities and
might continue trying until they succeed
so the result is a kind of a queueing
type phenomenon that happens as multiple
people are trying to match with the same
person so this this introduces some
interesting questions into the mix and
finally we're collecting data at an
astronomical rate you know both about
the supply and demand patterns about the
values people have but also about how
happy people were with their matches and
that's something we get by ratings and
reputation values on these various sites
so there's the opportunity to do very
fine-grained mining and actually have a
lot of impact on these these
marketplaces and the bottom line is it
creates a lot of new and challenging
research problems at the intersection of
algorithms economics machine learning
and stochastic optimization and I guess
in a nutshell this is kind of the topic
of our special semester if I were to put
it that way so let me just end by
mentioning one result that I was
involved with this is with all these
wonderful people here we were looking at
commodities of a temporal nature where
demand and supply fluctuate
stochastically over time so things like
cloud services or electricity markets
and we were interested in understanding
how effective we could be with posted
pricing that kind of takes into account
the variations in supply and demand so
the the natural approach here we were
looking at a stochastic setting the
natural approach here is to set prices
so that roughly at any point in time
expected demand and supply are balanced
however you have to deal with the fact
that sometimes because we're looking at
expectations here sometimes bad things
will happen and there could be cascading
bad events that occur in this kind of
system and basically what our results
shows is that good under some model
which I'm not explaining to you
roughly balancing the supply and demand
is sufficient to achieve high system
efficiency and basically this result is
sort of a combination of pricing and
queueing and online matching and a few
other things and I'm going to be talking
about it at the next workshop at Simons
if you're interested so I'm going to end
here I've sort of tried to give you a
sense of some of the questions that
we're trying to address we're dealing
with uncertain and dynamic inputs
opportunities for machine learning we
are making decisions obtain a strategic
behavior we have datasets that are too
large to store and we have the
opportunity to shape online marketplaces
and I think this creates many many
interesting research opportunities and I
thank you for your attention
sure that's my understanding I don't
know yeah I mean day work oh go ahead
my impression is that the assignment
problem was very important in the
development of some of the ideas about
the difference between polynomial time
in exponential time although the real
formalisms and you know the real
understanding came later I think
you
I got most of my information from
Shriver the the big yellow books so I'm
not an expert on this history by any
means it might be it's a difficult
question for me to answer but you know I
think that one of the great strengths of
worst-case analysis is that you have
this super strong guarantee so that in
that rare event
maybe it's rare I don't know that that
things look adversarial inputs look
adversarial your algorithm still works
well and in fact I should say that these
are worst case bounds on the running
time of the algorithm the algorithm
actually might run much faster in
practice so it also you know again it
could be that even this algorithm on the
stochastic inputs is close to optimal
for the stochastic inputs but at the
same time I think we're trying very hard
now to move beyond worst case and try to
understand better you know how to think
about questions so that we're both
addressing the worst case and addressing
the real stochastic nature of inputs